c'est la fin d'un long périple trois
jours de voyage pour valentina
grigorieva et ses deux enfants et une
famille enfin réunis loin de la guerre
et des bombardements
sergei huit ans n'arrive plus à contenir
son excitation que les forces militaires
et para tout de suite découvrir sa
nouvelle chambre
si une chambre d'hôte comme un refuge
inattendue pour trois femmes et leurs
cinq enfants mon fils me dit maman est
ce que tu es sûr que c'est la maison
nous est ce que c'est à nous ça wow wow
fia nous deux ça je dis bah oui
son compte
voici la seule photo du périple de ces
réfugiés leur arrivée à la gare de
vannes épuisé après des jours caché dans
un bunker denis pro leur ville bombardée
par les forces russes tom menaça borocz
à sedan on n'a pas eu le temps de
réfléchir on a pris le strict nécessaire
des médicaments nos documents comme nos
papiers d'identité des vêtements aussi
tout ce qu'on a pu mettre dans notre sac
l'ère où on applique si on a couru à la
gare et on est monté dans le premier
train qu'on a trouvée jusqu'à le vivre
et ils chantent zone mr aura une arrivée
en france rendue possible par yulia
apport à leurs cousines la famille -
versa ils sont arrivés d'ukraine il
avait ça sur le dos c'est tout ils ont
promis aux sommes restés au front de les
accueillir je vous avoue que je voyais
mes cousines installé dans un centre
pour réfugiés et au fait cette maison
c'est vraiment une chance des centaines
de dons pour aménager la maison des
dizaines d'heures de travaux pour tout
rénover une solidarité sans précédent
des habitants de la commune voilà le
ballon pour jouer
[Musique]
dès lundi les enfants doivent être
scolarisés les femmes travaillaient dans
l'entreprise de menuiserie familiale une
parenthèse avant de rentrer chez elle et
tenter de reprendre leur vie d'avant